I don’t keep a passcode on my phone, I just
make my life too boring to hack.
Hey iPhone Addicts, Jules here for Dnews!
It’s 2017, and passwords are soooo passé!
It goes without saying that our phones have
become our main confidants, and the information
on them; sacrosanct.
In the last few years, we’ve seen countless
variations on phone security, and new authentication
methods on the part of companies like Android
and Apple.
Things like fingerprint scanning, encrypted
passcodes, even complex patterns that have
to be inputted to gain access into the device.
But technology researchers will soon present
a scary reality at the Network and Distributed
System Security Symposium of 2017.
They used covertly taken video of someone
using Pattern Lock on their Android device
and paired it with computer vision algorithm
software, which was then able to produce the
correct pattern within just five attempts.
The software was able to do this by tracking
the victim’s fingertips, from as far as
2 and a half meters away.
So, if you thought Pattern Lock was safer
than a passcode, maybe it isn’t.
Plus, most people don’t use difficult to
guess patterns or passcodes, making the job
of cracking them even easier.
Some security analysts suggest that the method
of locking is less important than using multiple
encryption.
Most phones have an option where after a certain
limited number of attempts, the phone locks
itself down until you can get it to a computer
for validation, or it simply wipes the device
clean.
But even this encryption can be subverted
by making multiple copies of the phone’s
software.
So maybe the solution is to have a better
password than just a four digit number of
nine-point pattern.
A four digit pin has about 10,000 possible
combinations, a four-to-nine-point pattern
has closer to 400,000 combinations, but if
you use an actual, alphanumeric password,
the number of options increases exponentially.
Even if you use a five-character alphanumeric
password, with 90 different character options,
you’ll end up with almost six billion different
combinations.
That’s pretty secure.
But of course, if someone sees you input your
password, whether it be a camera, or just
someone looking over your shoulder, your security
is gone altogether.
So what about fingerprint scanning?
That’s safe, right?
Well, for starters, your fingerprint isn’t
really protected.
As we’ve talked about before on DNews, a
number of companies have shown that fingerprint
unlocking can be done using 3D printed prints.
In 2013, a hacking group called the Chaos
Computer Club took a photograph of a fingerprint,
laser printed it, poured rubber over the pattern,
and was able to use this mold to unlock a
phone.
And of course, there’s the less scientific
method of just knocking you out and pressing
your thumb against the phone.
And legally, a fingerprint is not even considered
a “password”.
That might seem obvious, but an important
example is if you are arrested and the police
want to go through your phone.
The Fifth Amendment says that you cannot be
compelled to provide self-incriminating evidence,
like a password, but according to a court
in Virginia, your fingerprint is not incriminating
information.
Other biometric ideas are in the works to
help keep phones secure, and may one day be
standard on all phones.
It’s already possible to recognize a designated
person using their heart-rate, their vein
pattern under the skin, even by the iris and
retina in the eye.
For now, it may just be a good idea to keep
sensitive data off your phone.
If you want to know more about how phones
can be hacked, check out this video here.
So that’s hacking your phone, but did you
know you can hack your body and implant technology
in it?
Our friends at Zoetic cover that in this video,
here.
And what do you guys use?
A pattern? a pin? a password?
Your fingerprint?
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to like and subscribe for more
DNews every day.